and backtracking a little bit you were
one of the first names that put their
toe in the Kickstarter water I mean you
were before Zach Braff Rob Thomas Spike
Lee James Franco how did that feel
because I mean definitely being new to
that and we've seen there's a lot of
backlash yeah two camps there's people
that think who you shouldn't have the
right to and then there's others that
say why not yeah and how was that for
you were you just at a point where
you're like you know what we're
hemorrhaging money what else could we
lose or was it a little bit there was
some trepidation on your part yeah it's
definitely a little bit of trepidation
but you know I for the Kickstarter
campaign we did for Kevin we were only
asking for fifteen thousand dollars and
it was really about as much as finishing
the documentaries about supporting Kevin
getting out into the world and I had
always felt with Kevin that I mean since
I first saw him when I was 20 years old
part of my life's mission subconsciously
was to like help the world know about
him and there was just a certain point
in time where I realized that the it
wasn't that calculated it was just like
oh this Kickstarter thing could start
that process right now and can help us
finish what we started so it was very
organic process and I felt I guess I
just felt really comfortable honestly
that it was coming from such a place of
love and support for him and what we
were trying to do together and and I and
I feel similarly about the you know the
manson family vacation project is it's
this is such a personal movie for jay
davis it's it's um it's something that's
been brewing in him for 40 years now and
I just it's in it's a really special
movie that you know we could do a lot of
things with this movie to kind of you
know I don't know make it more typically
commercial or whatever needs to be to
get more traditional funding but this is
really a very personal dark funny you
know artistic movie that
it you know we feel very strong about
how we want to make it and we're not
asking for a ton of money we're just
asking to make it the way that we feel
like is best and and so I feel good
about it I feel like it's an important
thing to do
you